I'm more than halfway through my week at
Lanterna
but last night's attempt at putting
freshly cooked food on the menu proves a
total disaster alex has a long way to go
if he's going to become a half-decent
Italian chef and his main cabin gives an
equally pathetic performance it's just
so frustrating when you show them time
and time again the perfect opportunity
for a great local Italian eatery in the
middle of a very wealthy town and you
can make such a great business out of it
but I don't know if they've got it you
jumped up little [ __ ] prick who the
[ __ ] you think you are because you as a
Maitre D' are [ __ ] useless I've done
it upset you so come back to me I'm
going to have to teach Gary how to get
tough if he's going to have any
authority tell me exactly what you think
right now what's going through your head
and get off your chair his staff and his
customers in the middle of a field
you've got to have Authority and
customers got a walk-in they're looking
for you yeah and you got to get a
reputation yeah at the moment I just see
this sort of little lost boy moping
around and there's things that go in on
that dining room that you should be
aware of yet you're totally clueless so
I'm really nervous that you're not
support and Alex properly so what I want
you to do is start getting angry right
what I did you send that start that
sounds like a [ __ ] [ __ ] in a
choir why the golden rule in any dining
room you have to be in control of your
staff like that not that you'll start
control you where is that food to start
that's not good enough you sound like a
right [ __ ] limp dick well the [ __ ]
are you doing taking the food to Table
six not Table seven
you [ __ ] idiot can you not read the
order in the kitchen excellent
Gavin needs to gain the respect of his
team so they know who's the boss then
you can start running the restaurant
with a bit of flair
oh you've really found your bollocks
okay give it all this time okay
what are you doing you stupid idiot
where is your [ __ ] brain tonight is
it up your arse